welcome to the video on the taylor
theorem and taylor polynomials and we've
actually already touched on this when we
did the videos on approximating
functions with polynomials we used
maclaurin series which is actually a
special case of the taylor polynomial or
the taylor theorem and we just
pick we approximate the function around
x equals zero when we did the maclaurin
uh series but in general you could
approximate a function around any value
and so what and and if you do it around
something other than zero it's kind of
the more general case and we're dealing
with the taylor polynomial so what is
that so let me just write the definition
down and then we'll do a couple of
examples and then we'll graph it to get
the intuition so a taylor polynomial
says that if i have a differentiable
function f of x
f of x and i want to approximate it
i want to approximate it with a
polynomial at c
so at some value of
x equals c i want to approximate this
function so let me just draw a quick and
dirty one and we'll actually draw
an accurate one later so let's say that
that's my
axes
this is my function
f of x
so i could pick some value c some value
x is equal to c
maybe it's right there
so that's c
and i would want to approximate it i
would want to create a polynomial that
can approximate the function around this
point and the taylor theorem tells us
that the the taylor polynomial to
approximate this is
and then i'll give you a i'll give you
the intuition for it in a second
p of x and this looks really complicated
when you do some examples you'll see
it's not so bad
p of x
is equal to
f
of c
plus
f prime
of c
times x minus c
plus
f prime prime
of c
over they say two factorials which is
just two but i'll okay i'll write two
factorial they do that so that you see
the pattern that emerges this is over 1
factorial really and this is over 0
factorial really
times
x minus c
squared
plus i'm already running out of space
f the third derivative i think at this
point people just write a three in
parentheses
of the function evaluated at c
over three factorial
times
x minus c to the third and you could
just keep adding terms you could go on
like this for infinity
but let me give you the intuition of of
what this is you know then i could let
me just show you just to hit the point
home so then you could plus the fourth
derivative
of the function evaluated at c times
over over four factorial times x minus c
to the fourth
now what's the intuition
so first of all what happens to this
polynomial at c
so what's p of c
p of c
is equal to
well if i stick a if i if at p of c
everywhere where you see an x here you
have to put a c right so this term would
be c minus c so that would go to zero or
it would be zero this term would be c
minus c it would be zero this term would
be c minus c should be zero this term
would be c minus c zero and all you'd be
left with is this f c
so great
we already know that at least at the
value of c
the polynomial is equal to the function
so it's going to intersect this line
right and actually if we just had a
taylor polynomial with just that first
term what would it look like would just
be a horizontal line right there so it
would be a pretty bad approximation
but what does the second term do is
because we know that we just evaluated
see all these other terms just drop out
so what do they do for us
well the second term actually ensures
that the derivative of this polynomial
evaluated at c is equal to the
derivative of this function evaluated at
c what do i mean there
well what's p prime of x
p prime
of x
is equal to well this is just a constant
term it might look like a function but
it's a function evaluated at c so it's
just a constant term
and so that's a zero and then what is
this what's the derivative of this
well the derivative we could use this is
a constant term and this is the
derivative of this is just 1.
so you could almost just view this as f
prime of c times x minus f prime of c
times c which is a constant whatever so
the derivative of this expression is f
prime of c
f prime
of c
and then plus the derivative of this
expression and that's equal to what 2
times 2
2 divided by 2 factorial which is just
one
so it's
f prime prime of c
times
x minus c
and then plus
let's see three over three factorial so
that's three over six so we'll just have
a two in the denominator f prime prime
prime
of c
over
was it 2 times x minus c to the
squared
and you don't have to worry about all of
this and then we could just keep going
but i wanted to show you one thing what
is p prime at c
p prime at c what is the derivative of
this polynomial when you evaluate it at
c
well when you put c in into this
derivative function all these other
terms are going to drop off and you're
just left with this one you're just left
with this one because right because
these x minus c
sorry i just had some walnuts i should
have had some water with it
if you put the c here
they drop out
so the derivative
of this function evaluated at c is equal
to
f prime
of c
so as you can see this taylor
what's neat about this taylor polynomial
is
it's equal to the function at c
its derivative is equal to the function
at c
the second derivative is equal to the
function at c and every term you add to
the taylor polynomial
actually makes it so that you know that
term derivative is eq at of the
polynomial evaluated at c is equal to
the function
hope i didn't confuse you the big
picture is
the the whole thinking behind i guess
what taylor thought of was wow you know
i can construct if
if this function is infinitely
differentiable meaning that i can take
the first second third fourth you know
all the way to infinity infinity
derivative of this function i could
construct a polynomial like this and i
could just keep going by adding more and
more terms so that
this polynomial's
you know zeroth derivative which is just
means you the function the zero first
second third fourth all of these
polynomials derivatives are going to be
equal to the function
at least around that point and actually
we'll see that there's actually a whole
class of functions that the taylor
polynomial if you were to take the
infinite series is actually equal
is actually equal to that function at
all points but anyway and actually i
talk a little bit about that when i
prove that e to the i pi is equal to
negative one which to me was the most
amazing um
the result in mathematics whatever
whatever but whatever this might have
been a little confusing for you so let's
do
a particular example
the particular the particulars are
always the more fun
i think when you see me do an example
you'll see that
it's not so bad i'm even going to erase
this fourth term
so let's approximate
i don't know cosine of x
so let's say that f of x is equal to cos
let me do a different color
we want to approximate f of x is equal
to cosine of x
and let's pick some arbitrary number
let's not pick some numbers that works
well with trigonometric functions let's
pick around or let's say c is equal to 2
no a 1.
so we're going to approximate cosine of
x around
the around 1.
so what is the taylor
approximation or the taylor polynomial
well we could just chug through this one
p of x i will do it in yellow
p
of x is equal to
f of c so the function evaluated at c is
just cosine
cosine of 1
right
plus f prime of c
well what is what is the derivative of
cosine of x it's minus sine of x right
minus sine of x and we have to evaluate
it at c so it's minus sine
minus sine
of one
right c is one that's what we're
approximating around times x minus c
and then plus the second derivative
plus the second derivative of x well
what's the second derivative what's
going to be the derivative of minus sign
which is minus cosine
of x
so it's minus cosine but we're
evaluating it at c so this is actually
going to be a number right so c is one
cosine of one
over two
right 2 factorial is just 2
times
x minus
1 squared oh sorry this should be a 1.
right i said c is equal to 1
times x minus 1 squared
let's keep going plus the third
derivative
plus what's the third derivative of
cosine
well it's the derivative of minus cosine
so that's plus sign
so plus
sine evaluated at one sine of one
divided by three factorial so that's six
over six
times x minus three
to the third
so
my brain is really i hate too many
walnuts
undo edit undo x minus 1 to the third
right and then let's do one more term
just just just for fun
so then we're going to take the fourth
derivative which is the derivative of
the third derivative
so the third derivative was positive
sign so now we're going to be plus
cosine
plus cosine
evaluated at one
over 4 factorial what's 4 factorial it's
3 factorial times 4 so over 24
times x minus 1 to the fourth and we can
just keep going the fifth derivative
over 5 evaluated at 1 over 5 factorial
times x minus 1 to the 5th and just keep
adding but then it'll take us forever et
cetera et cetera
so
what does this thing look like and what
i'm going to do is i'm going to show you
how this polynomial develops as we add
terms
so let's see i have this
this graphing calculator that i
so this thing i got from just to give
them credit it's my my.hrw.com
and this is the graph of cosine of x
so just the first term here
cosine of 1. if we were to just graph
the first term of this polynomial what
does it look like
so i'll just type in cosine
of 1
and graph it
so there you go just the first term of
the polynomial if all of these terms
these other terms weren't here the
polynomial would just be a constant
right cosine of one
and it's a pretty bad approximation but
at least it equals the function at this
point so it gives us some it gives us
something
both let's add some terms let's add the
second term to it so it was the second
term
it was sine of 1
minus sine of 1 times x minus 1. so let
me add that
so minus sine
of 1
times
x i know x minus 1
graph it
there you go so this is neat so when you
just added two terms what did we say the
function will equal
the the polynomial
equal to the function at
at our
x equals one and now the slope is also
equal to the function the slope of the
polynomial is also equal to the slope of
the function at x is equal to 1. so this
is a better approximation at least if we
stay pretty close to our chosen c
we're pretty we're it's a decent
approximation for
for the uh for the function now
obviously if we get far away out here
this is a horrible approximation for the
function let's keep adding terms as you
can see i just want to show you that
i'm just typing in i'm just typing in
the actual
term so let me type in the next term i
want to
just just so you believe that i'm doing
it
so the next term well i have to see it
so let me type it in so
the next term is
minus
cosine
of 1
divided by 2
times
x
times x minus 1
squared
and let me graph it
okay
so now just to show you i just typed in
the second term
and now let's look at the graph
now this is neat
right so the first term got us a
horizontal line that just intersected
the point at cosine of one and it was a
really bad approximation then when the
second term made sure at least the first
derivative was the same
and so then we the line was just
essentially the tangent line we only had
two terms now the third term make sure
that
it makes sure that the second derivative
of our polynomial
at
at x equals one is equal to the second
derivative of the polynomial
of of the function and notice that
this this green graph is concave
downwards right which means that and and
so is and so is the function at one so
this is this is pretty neat we're
getting a little bit so it's kind of
approximating the curve
here it's getting a little bit better
remember when we went out far to the
left it's starting to approximate the
function better around here it's closer
at least right the last time the line
just went up and here was a really bad
approximation
but let's add another term let's add our
third term our third term i can see it
it's right there
so
plus
sine of one divided by six
times
x minus one
to the third power
just to show you i just typed it in
right there
it's minus one to the third power let me
graph it
that is neat
just with three terms on our polynomial
well actually what that was uh right
just with three terms well actually
that's the fourth term officially one um
but the the first term was was was
essentially well anyway you you get the
point but we're already starting to
approximate this pretty well
right now the third derivative
is equal to the the third derivative of
the polynomial is equal to the third
derivative of the function at the point
x equals equal to one and we haven't
even studied the derivatives that's kind
of like the the you know the concativity
of the derivative or whatever but as we
can see it approximates the function
even better obviously though when we go
further away it starts to break down
again but pretty close if this is if all
you saws from here to here it'd be hard
to tell them apart
let's add that last term we calculated
and this should be pretty neat let's see
the last term
plus
cosine of 1
divided by 24 and notice every term the
the scaling factor
right here is one then one half then one
sixth one 24th
it becomes a smaller impact on it and it
only starts to matter as you move really
really far away from your chosen c in
this case one right
the the further out you go when you're
close to your your point that you picked
these these other terms don't matter
much right because you're doing one
twenty fourth and then one over five
factorial etcetera etcetera but as you
get further and further away this these
terms become more significant right as x
gets further and further away from one
and then that's where these start to
play in and you see that in the
approximation anyway let me graph it
so
cosine of 1 divided by 24
times
x minus 1
to the fourth
let me graph it
even neater and if you have some spare
time you might just want to keep adding
terms to this so that's all the taylor
polynomial is and i realize this is
probably one of the longest videos i've
done i'm pushing 17 minutes it's a
little confusing at first because it
gives you this huge formula and they
give you the c and you're like what is
that c and how do i take the derivative
when you actually try to chug through it
you just have to realize oh
all this is is saying we are
constructing a polynomial
that
at some point c that we picked
this polynomial's zero first second
third fourth fifth and so on derivative
is going to be equal to our function and
actually if we did you know if we did
ten terms or if we did all of the
derivatives these these would start to
actually equal each other so hopefully
that didn't confuse you i know it's kind
of a
a uh when you see the formula at first
it can be kind of daunting and
especially um
sometimes it's even more daunting when
someone even explains it to you but
hopefully that gave you some intuition
if it didn't ignore this video see you
soon